[Música]
[Aplausos]
momentos antes mas obrigado pelo convite
obrigado estarem presentes eu vou falar
sobre o que nós estamos a viver e
terminaram hoje em dia que a quarta
moção industrial onde temos máquinas são
seriam um dia no cleto isso que mascam
processo de conversão e mandando essa
informação para outras máquinas
essa função está a alterar a forma com
um nós vivemos e trabalhamos
eu nasci aqui e câmera seu amigo em 54 e
gosta há uma uma conferência com de pela
primeira vez é usado por um jovem na
carta e que o termo inclusive ficar
difícil disse ao estado na base da
quarta posição industrial não estamos a
viver o em 300 fiscal
esta é a altura teve várias
desenvolvimento social 'tratava' modelos
computacionais a ambientes complexos de
robótica processamento da linguagem
metrõ apresentação do conhecimento em
computadores linguagem de programação
para passar conhecimento
o portugal ter envolvido nesses
envolvimento texto os anos 70 que existo
o comportamento enfrentar que tenham
iniciado não fez boa no não sabe porquê
desses textos anos 80
top contribuições importantes no
desenvolvimento
iguais para programas em lógica de
programação para processamento da
linguagem eletrônica nesta fim nesta
figura que representa com 11 pontos
cruciais no desenvolvimento enfrentar
portugal aparece aqui um português
o fernando pereira esteve ligado por
exemplo ao google translate é maior que
o desenvolvimento ongd ao cliente a
melhor em um shopping de los angeles
temos uma convicção é que é certo e
ainda não fala para veículos
foi a primeira vez que um veículo que
partiu fazer tudo terminar com o sérgio
em 2005 300 km de forma completamente
copa em pleno séc vá não é é a primeira
vez é o primeiro história de sucesso do
veículo só parou
jack é terminar e os partindo crime só
de música mas ninguém faz tanto na
altura estava num instante forte lembra
se de um soco lugar com o google em
conquistar no desenvolvimento do carro
da google qualquer neste momento circula
na califórnia
eu espero que eu queria vê lo não muito
longe já no apagar aquilo é mesmo um dos
temas o que é considerado manifestações
de 200 jogos
eu lembro que o flamengo sempre teve
equipas muito fortes
o jogador foi exatamente está nas foi o
primeiro jogo foi implementado o
programa de computador para jogar acho
isto é o artur emanuel fun que
desenvolveu o jogo também tinha um
aspecto muito interessante que era um
jogo que era capaz de aprender a nos
computadores apreendidos em duas formas
uma e porque são ensinados às centenas
isto é uma boa opção aquela maximiza
idade vários exemplos de boas posições e
mais que isso o computador aprenda
discriminar o que é uma boa posição na
posição e posteriormente quando vai
jogar vai escolher as suas posições
outra forma de aprender com a
experiência e este jogo mas aprendi a
ter a experiência aprendi jogando com
crianças mesmo em 62 o programa de
samuel venceu uma
hoje em dia o programa de samuel não
perde por não treinar mas não opera
atenção os marcos importantes no jogos
computacionais a um marco fundamental
que em 97 quando o de bugandan é o caso
de carol castro para ver um campeão de
xadrez tendo mundo certeza nessa altura
em dois dias em cascavel está convencido
que havia um mandado por trás da máquina
bom dia em 90 em 2016
o qual foi bôa e é né ao campeão do
mundo do gol que o jogo tem 80 uma
complexidade muito maior que o do xadrez
aprendizagem por computador o computador
se aprendem a partir de facto de
observações e nós assistimos a um
crescimento exponencial da informação
digital toda a informação é nada pela
pela humanidade em 86 99% será na loja e
1% era digital em 2007 94% e digital de
6% e 9 11 hoje em dia
99.9 por cento e digital e 0.1 por cento
é é inspiração é essa informação digital
que vai permitir a capacidade de
aprendizagem das máquinas quantidade de
informação que a gente conecta hoje em
dia é fenomenal está uma notícia do
público sobre as presas para a
descoberta do bóson de higgs não serve
um segundo destas experiências geravam
datos que daria para encher saiu séries
e esta questão um shows que levantava
nosso gemia coletamos muita informação
o problema não é coletado em relação ao
problema é perceber essa compreender
essa informação
em 2001 o relatório do fmi aqui se
sustenta em 2001 que as tecnologias
emergentes vão mudar o mundo a uma delas
etapa
está na altura quando o google começa a
direcionar a publicidade com o chileno a
amazônia começa a mandar argumentações
tribos aos seus clientes em 2011
na quinta o instituto público o
relatório está o clima na net sobre a
próxima fronteira a inovação competição
por não ter vida e tem sobre diversos
setores industriais reais ensino e
investigação com um a aprendizagem
automática vai influenciar na prática no
dia a gente aprende a partir do estádio
e voltar para casa os concretos em que
estiver envolvido e que ilustrou o que
nós consideramos aprender quando eu
vivia um amigo ela nem toda a gente
inclusive toda a gente toda a gente nem
se reuniar e seria eu o senhor recebia
preferiu pão desta forma alan outra casa
um tempo de augusta que prossegue hoje
em dia a gente vai às grandes
superfícies e é nome de ninguém mas para
tudo tem saído sempre que eu faço não é
compra essa compra fica registado numa
barraca com aquilo que eu comprei as
empresas começam a explorar essas partes
status
pra tentar compreender o cliente
perceber as preferências
o que elas gostam que elas preferem o
tipo de análise que eu faço aqui
ilustrado isto é os carrinhos compras de
um terreno e o comprou o time ser ao
menos um milhar centenas de milhares de
carrinho de compras e milhar centenas
milhares de produtos irão enfrentar
essas diversas carrinhas compras
eu posso chegar a conclusões do tipo por
exemplo sempre que o espro tem contato
com o produto também é comprar
tipicamente não é nem pela extensão
lógica uma implicação provável lista
existe incerteza acerca da lista e eu
posso usar isto é crescimento
estes são factos isto é conhecimento e
na atração do chat e eu posso
operacionalizar esse conhecimento e
profissionalismo
por exemplo os cupões de funções que são
enviados para vossas casas nos cenários
passar dos factos a este processo e
passar factura de vencimentos e nas
aprendizagens
isto é outro caso tudo isto e facebook
twitter rede social facebook a partir da
análise desta rede social identifico-me
nada eu posso dizer isto e são os meus
amigos do amigo do liceu
esses são os meus amigos do instituto de
investigação das conferências da
comunidade internacional começou no
carro não me falou dessa renda
eu consigo saber qual é o papel das tuas
indivíduos um central idade e de turno
tá ligado dentro menina conseguiu
identificar as comunidades e consigo
perceber o papel das ligações nesta
escuridão
estamos de maneira explícita a muitas
redes sociais hoje em dia e conseguiu
entre implícitas por exemplo quando eu
faço uma chamada transforme estou a
definir uma agenda implícita entre nós
são pessoas e dois não estão ligados se
chama o outro eu possa analisar os
fósseis fez um filme the strong é nem
sequer fazia era analisar desatento
essas redes isto é lamentação
isto é o mapa do porto e e estão o
sistema começaram em tempo real ataca um
táxi quando terminam serviço ir para uma
praça takaki
nós temos ainda são exatamente os times
que eu também não sabia disso
nosso sistema menda para qual é a praça
taksim onde com melhor procurar fra -
quem espera está envolta fazer previsão
a curto prazo qual vai ser a polícia
eles foram parceiros em cada uma dessas
em cada uma das praças de táxi um quarto
disto caso é do hospital são joão estão
antes que o público em 2014 quando o
hospital fechamos envolve um sistema que
é vital que a natureza e agrega uma toda
a informação acerca dos doentes estão em
cuidados intensivos
esta informação é utilizada em tempo
real pelos médicos e do filme
de cabeça assim e indicar riscos cuidado
buscando agripos detenção de tendências
para concluir isto é é com vai isto é
expectativas e ao longo do tempo
quando há uma inovação tecnológica a um
pico inflacionado expectativa seguido um
fila até chegar ao placo uma das
empresas
a fé é uma das empresas de moda de luxo
que não tem nem a companhia de táxis
eu não tentar se é compreender e se
transforma em gás companhia informa que
o skype que não têm infraestrutura de
telecomunicações produz melhor conteúdo
social media é o facebook não tem
jornais nem nada só fornece uma
plataforma com nós produzimos senhora
cinema cinemas
o melhor hotel web e não tem edifício
nós vivemos em um mundo cada vez mais
para disto alização do real
nós temos o nosso óleo novo tron
o futuro está para a data saia
está sabendo disto é a profissão mais
sexy para o século 21
vocês podem ver emprego estão a
desaparecer
sempre há uma função industrial a
empresa e sem pressa ea outros empregos
que aparecem as expectativas é que vai
haver muito mais um crescimento no mundo
empregos nas pessoas mais qualificadas
obrigado pela atenção
[Aplausos]